e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs as noticed
we uh have several bills scheduled today
uh for executive session but before we
get into those I'd ask you to please
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
everyone okay the first bill for our
consideration this morning is Senate
Bill 355 FN representative
kofalt uh I move itl on SB 355
FM is there a second representative mlan
you second representative kofalt did you
want to speak to your motion sure I I
think um you know my my concern here is
that we are um sort of expanding the
scope of recommended procedures uh for
newborns um it is advisory and yet
advisory practices um often carry a lot
of weight advisory practices often U
morph at a later date into mandatory
practice is um I think that this is an
unnecessary Bill and that is why I moved
Barber
sorry thank you Mr chairman
um
I oppose the itl I think this was an
entirely benign bill that recognized
that adding another screening procedure
was not appropriate and uh the
encouragement for education is always
the way that I think is the most
appropriate way to go so um I will for
that reason I would have preferred a
motion of ought to pass but here we are
so I am opposing the motion of itl thank
discussion okay I guess it's easy in
that regard anyway okay so the motion is
itl on Senate Bill 355 FN I'll ask the
all representative kofalt
yes representative ner
yes uh the clerk votes
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel I'm sorry not here uh
representative POF
yes representative Weber no
representative McKay no Representative
fedus no representative Canon
no representative Nutter upam no
representative Shapiro
no representative
Merchant representative Murphy
no representative Palmer
tez excuse me and representative
McDonald yes who was uh who is
representative ning for today
representative kushman okay got it sorry
I should have not believe that's the
only substitute we have this morning I
don't know of any others Y and the vote
is 8 to8 8 to8
okay I representative
Weber I would move a to pass
representative Weber moves a to pass is
there a second representative Murphy
seconds should we
caucus
um I'm sorry who asked for a caucus I
was thinking maybe it would be a good
time to caucus now are you requesting a
caucus okay
we I don't think that was the bill we
were talking about needing a cockus far
was
it I'm sorry representative TZ has
arrived and we are no longer evenly
split oh okay all right good point all
right all right well we'll uh we'll have
caucus
go
e
okay we'll reconvene at this
point thank you for your patience um the
motion on the floor is ought to pass on
355 FN representative Lon you wish to
speak to this motion yes thank you Mr
chairman and I apologize not for not
being here for the previous discussion I
was introducing a bill bill over in
Senate HHS um I recognize the motivation
and the importance behind this bill um
one of the big things that we need to
recognize however is that the largest
indicator for needing a CMV test is
failing the hearing screening and the
hearing screening is not part of the
newborn screening that is something that
is done by the hospitals as good
practice adding something to a voluntary
good practice effort that's part of the
newborn screening system that's required
seems to be a little odd to me right now
we need to focus on the specific
necessary need where if there is a child
who a newborn who fails the hearing
screening twice they should be tested
for CMV and that should be standard
practice across hospitals in New
Hampshire the fact that it's not is um
is the problem but I think one that
through education even without this bill
we can address um the idea of trying to
wrap in something that comes after a
voluntary step just seems to be um not
the right way to legislate and I believe
that that's why um had I been in the
room I would have moved itl because
while while this is an important I
recognize that um I'm trying to I I
represented one of our bills over in the
senate had I been here I would have made
that motion because while it is
important to understand the risks of CMV
there's also the risk of scaring parents
needlessly for a disease that is highly
prevalent often does not lead to
negative outcomes and where antiviral
treatment carries its own risks from
that treatment so the idea of telling a
parent well your baby has this disease
nothing's probably going to happen we
could give them medicine but that
medicine might hurt them that gives a
parent who is anxious nervous and trying
to do the right thing for their baby one
more thing to worry about when that's
something to leave to the professionals
and leave to their professional judgment
um that's why I believe that while this
is a well-intentioned bill I don't think
this is the right solution and I I think
that we should look to um we should look
to a different approach so thank you
representative
Weber and I'm going to pick up on the um
point about education and just say that
I think encouraging education is a good
thing and we should trust both medical
professionals and parents but this bill
is encouraging education and I'm going
to vote for it thank you
other
discussion I'm seeing none okay motion
is ought to pass on SB 355
FN I'll ask the clerk to call the wall
representative Lon
no represent n
no CL votes
nay Representative kofalt
no Representative mlan no
representative Seth King
no representative Missour no
representative
Nagel representative POF
no representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus representative Canon yes
representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative TZ yes and
representative McDonald no 10 to
10 okay so this will be going to the
floor with AO
recommendation um I would remind
everyone who'll be authoring reports
that we're up against the deadline on
all of these early bills and that they
all need to be in as soon as possible
represent U Christina D was in the back
listening to this and we'd be most
grateful if we get these in
by early afternoon right possible I was
obviously as early in the day as
possible also Mr chairman I need to go
back over to the Senate I don't know if
we want to do one with an amendment I'll
be back as soon as I can okay you all
right thank you uh I also I would like
to announce uh there was an early bill
that escaped our attention there was um
data entry area uh data entry error in
the clerk's office uh it's the first
bill will be hearing tomorrow morning um
SB
FNA representative Weber and I met with
the clerk and we will be hearing that
first thing tomorrow morning and
executing it right after because it is
an early Bill they're holding the
calendar for it and again we're up
against that deadline and I believe it's
U representative where Senate uh me
house will
44b I think that's the one the clerk
cited it's one about firefighters right
firefighters and cancer screenings and
so we're in agreement that we we will if
the chairman and the ranking member
agree we can we can execute tomorrow
even though it's not noticed and
otherwise the bill would have to be
withdrawn entirely and we we don't want
to do that representative notr up them
what uh same time um it's uh it's it's
actually the um
yeah yeah whatever those calendar says
um yeah at 9:30 MH you'll be it'll be
203 okay so um and so again yeah reports
please get them in uh right away um can
I representative
Weber could I just say I know that
several of us need substitutes for
tomorrow so if you could let the
Democratic office know um perhaps quick
text
um so that they can try and find you a
sub if you need a sub if you don't we'll
just go ahead and hope for the best and
deal with it on the floor and likewise
with the Republican office if any of you
I'm I haven't heard from anyone but if
anyone does need to be I have a
replacement please uh please let the
Republican office know and let me
know okay
um so we are down one okay um well we
can at least start the discussion
representative Warby of our
parliamentarian but we can at least
start the discussion on SP 403 FN I
would I would
expect we can start any discussion and
hold any vote the only thing that bars
somebody voting is they must be in the
room when the question is put so when we
get to the end of the discussion and and
we're going for a vote so we can have a
general discussion but no motion can be
made well you can you can have a motion
it's just I some people have the mo
motions first in the discuss afterwards
you can do it anyway around it's just if
somebody when when you get to the point
of saying the motion is ought to pass as
amended and ask and somebody has not
been and asked the clerk to call the
role if they walk in after that all
right they can't vote okay
great all right well with that um thank
you representative Weber let's go to 403
SB 403 FN I have an amendment uh that
the department asked me to offer and I
would move it to do option SP 403 FN do
I have a
second could we see it uh we I
distributed it at the last meeting last
week oh okay it is amendment 1533 H and
pass it out uh as we toward the end of
the hearing on uh 495 last
Wednesday I don't know if everybody
brought it with them or still has it in
their
distributed um
I would think it would be on the website
might we have copies anywhere okay or
might representa miss is getting up um
get us copies not on the I'm sorry about
one hasn't been second Mr chairman which
was what was the number on that
I guess I should have held off
Distributing the amendment but I wanted
people to see it in advance of this this
session so Miss D has left the room I
assume she's getting copies po she took
one and there is a copy machine right
back
there you should have known it would be
a challenging day when the sun didn't
come out
right and I'm sorry I'm I mean it it's
probably just me so um no it's not it's
not just me okay thank
you that was
kindness it
was
second I don't believe it was second oh
we hadn't gotten there yet yeah we
haven't gotten there yeah because you
pointed out that we there was no copy of
multi
saw St
[Music]
representative Co said you might one as
Welling the wrong one thank
okay Christina da once again comes
through thank you very
much okay so I'll reiterate my motion of
ought to pass on 403 FN do I have a
second second thank you representative
Merchant uh it was the amendment you
were moving not the right yeah the
amendment for 15 33h that Christina Dyer
just
distributed um I will um I'd like to add
we have an attorney here from the office
of professional license ger and
certification I'd like him to come
forward I was I introduced this
amendment uh at that request and it was
um you with his help that I drafted it
and I want anytime we consider any
legislation I want every agency to feel
they've been given a fair shake and all
information relevant to the issue is
being considered and for that reason I
was happy to introduce this amendment uh
sponsor this amendment and um this time
I'll recognize the gentleman before us
don't forget to put your microphone on
please and state your name sure good
morning my name is Douglas osterhout and
I am general counsel for the office of
professional LIC Insurance certification
uh I did craft the majority of the
language I believe in this amendment uh
the purpose behind that is um about two
years ago there was a study committee
representative Merchant was on that
committee uh who made some
recommendations about the roles and
responsibilities between the office of
Professor liur and certification and the
boards we oversee and uh we made some
changes or the legislature made some
changes to that um as far as uh fees
setting Authority who issues licenses
that sort of thing it's a work in
progress we had a very large Bill last
year that was around 200 Pages parts of
that bill uh were or parts of the
language were taken out this year is
sort of round two of just clean up
making sure there's no conflicting
language in statute um originally this
fall we thought we were going to move
forward sort of with wave two of cleanup
then we were told no then in the spring
it ended up happening so my original
plan was to address any language that
conflicted with sp sp 403 with the oplc
statutes in the bill we did next year
since it ended up moving forward this
year I thought now would be the right
time to make sure the language in s sp43
does not conflict with RSA 310 and the
board's practice acts so basically
that's a long way of saying this is a
very technical Amendment it doesn't
change anything policy-wise and it just
makes sure that the language in here
comports with the oplc Practice Act and
the board's Practice Act happy to take
questions any representative
Merchant thank you for taking the
question correct I think what I read in
here is the clarification to who issues
the license but the standards for the
license is controlled by the board so
the board is the one controlling the
requirements for a license but the
actual physical issuing of the license
is done by oplc not the board that is
100%
correct other
questions okay seeing Oh representative
Weber thank you I'm I'm somewhat
concerned sure uh at the late
introduction of a change of this
magnitude simply because I have heard in
the past that there have been times
when the individual boards and the
office of professional lure have not
been
entirely uh in agreement about where
those boundary lines are and so I'm very
anxious about passing this without
giving everybody the opportunity for a
real full public hearing that
said I do believe that the changes are
technical in nature and it is going to
another committee um so I fervently hope
that anybody who has concerns with it
will be given appropriate notice of that
point uh because it's it's concerning
that a shift like this happens without a
significant amount of
notice representative Merchant thank you
Mr chairman also thank you for taking
the question on line nine
what was the impetus behind adding
employed as a licensed nursing assistant
for one full year where did that come
from who who uh wanted that language
inserted because it goes back to what
represent Weber is saying are we is this
something that oplc is requesting or
something the board is requesting
because it's important if it's requested
by the board it makes sense was the
original Bill what
s okay but again go back to who was the
one cuz I wasn't here for the hearing
who was the one that that wanted it
inserted it was not the
oplc representative representative Weber
I will just say that that was in the
bill as it was sent to us from the
Senate so at least people had
notice representative TZ you had your
hand
up thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I was we're trying
to reconcile the amendment sections in
the amendment um
beginning where was it uh line 24 on the
amendment says amend uh 326 and3 as
inserted by section six of the bill by
replacing it so I just want to make sure
that that's not trying to replace all of
section six right it's just beginning on
line 14 of the uh second or third
page yeah I'm trying to understand the
motivation like what is that change
pertaining
to having a little difficulty following
the bouncing ball there so if we're
looking at the original bill is that the
reference page two line 14 page two line
Senate you talking about the amendment
of The Bill I'm trying to I'm trying to
understand the differences here again
going back to the it's a lot of
change it's okay well my first question
was you're not replacing the whole
section six you're just replacing
sections so that wasn't completely clear
um and then trying to
understand where where it says uh 326
and
3 rule making there's a fair amount of
difference between what was originally
drafted and so just trying to understand
sorry you asked a question
representative TZ right yes yes per and
he's looking and trying to find the I
just wanted to make sure I wasn't
no and could I elaborate while he's
looking just yes representative Weber
finding things in the bill itself or the
bill as we got it from the Senate it
appears to me that if I look up 326
colon n 3 rulemaking which is
what um is being amended here it starts
with a very long list of things that are
going to be done or not done and that
list doesn't seem to be in the amendment
so if you could walk us very carefully
through that section I think it would
help a great deal of us and it's online
line 24 of the amendment but I if you
page through the bill it is section six
and then when you go down to 326 and
three Ru making it's got the same
caption at least yeah apologies that was
line 14 of Page Three not line 14 of
okay I've found all the language I've
also got notes explaining the decisions
that I made I'm just trying to line it
up with my notes so that I don't have
work I I think we probably should stick
to one one and then we'll move forward
with the other question
all right so if if we're looking at 326
and3 the rul making uh the executive
director in consultation within New
Hampshire area health education centers
adopt rules prent to RSA
541a relating to the following the
certification is voluntary it doesn't
appear that there is a board tied to
this certification in this bill so it's
more of a registry so this is one of
those cases where it's going to work
more like an an Advisory Board uh or
other registries that we have within the
office
and um the executive director will work
with New Hampshire area health education
centers to adopt rules relating to the
following in the criteria and I believe
that is the language in the original
bill as it was
proposed um section A would
establishment and administration for a
voluntary program for certification of
community health
workers that stay in the amendment
minimum and continuing education
training
qualifications all stayed in the bill um
forms procedures for the receipt review
and action upon
applications establishment of standards
for continuing education can I interrupt
you for a moment representative has a
point of point if I look at the bill as
sent To Us by the Senate that whole
section 326 in3 rulemaking starts the
executive director shall in consultation
with the New Hampshire area health
education centers adopt rules relating
to the following and it's got it starts
out the
same
okay and
then I'm just trying to find out if this
is a ruming thing um it's more of a
redundancy thing it but but under the
original bill there's four sections and
then subsections and none of those
appear to be in the bill as you're
submitting it to us correct on did you
have additional information yes on the
in the original Bill lines 24 through 36
are removed but the rest of that R
making section is there and um the part
about administering the fees which is um
currently Roman 2 on page four lines 3
through five is gone I believe because
that's included in the new N4 um but in
the rul making um it it keeps lines 14
through 23 of the original Bill page
three and then it keeps lines 1 through
four I can I can walk you through that
too if you'd like so I think a walk
through would be helpful on that because
uh the section the the version of the
original bill that I have is not lined
it doesn't have line representative
Merchant you wanted to speak thank you
as we're going through this process I go
back to my question I asked earlier
about the role of oplc versus the role
of aort I have a real deep concern that
when you talk about rule making that the
rule making is not going through the
Board review process this is dealing
with licensed nursing assistants which
come under the jurisdiction of the Board
of Nursing not OP PLC so in saying that
I
would strongly oppose the fact that the
executive director who's not required
even work with the Board of Nursing
working with Healthcare educational
centers and on top of that when you
start looking at what they're going to
go through rulemaking it goes through
the requirements for that certification
which is the education the training
experience that belongs under
professional board and not the office of
professional certification in my opinion
representative TZ yeah sorry this is
confusing because there's too much in
this huge bill this section we're
talking about is community health
workers that is not a nursing profession
it is a lay profession for which there's
been many years of work towards creating
a certific voluntary certification
process there is no entity that would be
the appropriate entity except now
figuring out that somehow sharing that
between DHHS
this the ahex who've been doing all the
work of the training for years and the
oplc um so so it's not nursing then why
are we calling a licensed nursing
assistant it's a different section of
the Bill thank
you thank
you representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um my question is if there are
other areas where essentially lay people
are certified without an Advisory Board
in order to set standards that are in
vulnerable situations um with with
people in the state is that something
that's done in other sections of oplc or
is this a novel pathway do you know it's
rare but it's not unheard of I believe
opdal dispensers are a registry without
a board I believe there was uh there's
proposed legislation it's confusing some
of it happened last year this year it's
getting assigned to us but for uh
lactate Specialists and duelist would be
interesting I'm just going to use the
word thing what we oversee now with the
traveling nurses the companies that
oversee traveling nurses now have to
register with us there is no board so
it's not a common thing but it's also
not
unique representative L um thank you and
as a followup um AIC
dispensers um dual
lactation Consultants all um are not
operating on their own they're all in
conjunction with other licensed
professionals under a board um I believe
correct i' have to look at the
legislation for that I we haven't
implemented like du and lactate
Specialists they're not with us yet so I
have to see how those puzzle pieces fit
okay but in their practice they are and
then it would be the traveling nurse
associations not the nurses which
themselves are licensed correct so this
idea of having somebody go into
somebody's home
that's not directly overseen by somebody
and providing Health Care is uh is a
step outside of what we' already have
established even if we are working
towards it in other areas no it's it's a
new
section I think the closest comparison
here is probably alal
dispensers thank you yeah
yeah so I believe you were going through
the bill and and trying to clarify some
things before we got into some questions
but if you want to resumed sure uh so
I'm on page three of the bill as amended
by the Senate line 24 so uh it would be
326 and three and it's just Roman
numeral
1B uh forms and procedures for the
receipt review and action upon
applications for initial community
health workers Etc uh this Authority is
already granted in proposed 326
n31a which requires the executive
director to adopt rules for the
establishment and administration of a
voluntary program so
believ the language just to be redundant
so I just removed it um section c right
below that establishment of standards
for continuing education and other
requirements uh the executive director
has regulatory Authority Under proposed
RSA 326 and3 the executive director is
required to consult with the New
Hampshire area health education centers
pursuant to proposed 326 N3 Roman
numeral one my suggestion would be to
add the commissioner to to that list so
the Ed consults with the education
centers and commissioner that's what I
wrote in my uh draft I sent with to
representative McDonald that's a policy
decision just a recommendation um strike
all of D I suggested because Ru making
Authority for D already exists in RSA
310 colon 6 Roman numeral
2 uh the E the determination assessment
and collection of certification fees Etc
r exists in RSA 310 colon 6 Roman
numerals 1 and
two and F other well I didn't change
that I just changed commissioner to
executive director so basically it was
just to remove any redundancy in the
statute where the rulemaking authority
are already exists within the office in
3106 so that was my goal there um one of
the things we're up against and the
reason we have to do
multiple Omnibus bills is whenever we
make or grant that same Authority in one
place if we put it in two or three
places we have to change all of the the
purpose of that consolidation in 310 was
to avoid that
course okay any other discussion on the
amendment representative Nagel did did
you want me what's an Opthalmic
dispenser they just Opthalmic I don't
sorry uh I believe it's um is it contact
lenses I'm not entirely sure I I deal on
the administrative side not the scope of
practice side so I don't really have
useful
information Bill well it is in the sense
that we're comparing the right but it's
not part of Bill representative Shapiro
so in regard to your initial comments
about um
aligning this bill with changes that are
coming would it be safe to say
that across
oplc um the
boards will will not issue licenses and
certifications it will be oplc that's
the that's the technical that's correct
yes sir okay and also follow
um in regard to representative
Merchant's question before about um line
nine um letter B has employed as a
licensed nursing assistant for one year
I think we heard during the hearing that
that makes a change from two years which
is not in statute but is in rules so
it's kind of Bringing Down the standard
so that more people can get um this
ability to provide a medication
thank you any other questions for this
gentleman I'm seeing none okay thank
you any other discussion on the
H seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
a roll motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 1533
H representative Lon yes representative
ner yes yes votes
no Representative mlan
no representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
no representative Nagel
yeah Representative pela
no representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative
Fus representative Canon yes
representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representative tez
yes and represent McDonald
yes 16 to
4 the amendment passes 16
to4 and um this point uh do I have
another motion representative poal did
you have a motion uh yes I move itl on
Senate Bill 403 second representative
Leon seconds the motion do you wish to
speak to your motion
representative yes um I am very
concerned with the creation of a uh
a a new um lenser position community
health
workers um I'm concerned especially
about some of the the definitions
offered here um including for
example
um in providing informal and
motivational counseling so informal uh
I'm sorry motivational counseling I
think I understand informal
counseling um
I think is very poorly defined there is
another provision in this that says they
shall not perform any any duties that
are um performed by somebody who would
require other certifications or
licenses um so I think this is an
extraordinarily fuzzy definition um on
line 28 it says that community health
workers would provide other services as
defined by uh
rulemaking um that seems to me to be a
wide open door so while I think we heard
from some people who are community
health workers that they are very
committed to their jobs they feel like
they're making a
difference um I guess I would I would
ask the question um how do we know that
this is truly effective um how far will
the government reach into people's lives
we heard one person um attest to the
fact that uh she was helping people with
things like um advising them to tape
down a carpet so they don't trip over it
um and just as importantly perhaps how
far will government reach into people's
pockets because somebody has to pay for
this and this bill creates a
reimbursement mechanism um in which uh
in which we would be paying for people
whose responsibilities I believe are um
extraordinarily uh vaguely defined open
to expansion through
rulem and um and I I just think that
this is a bad precedent to set thank you
representative Leon did you want to
speak to you a second or um yes Mr
chairman thank you very much um so this
is an area where we need to look at what
we're doing what powers we're giving and
most importantly what we're making the
public see when they see the
certification
um with this certification from the
state and the ability to Bill people
were are going to expect a lot out of
these community health workers they're
going to expect that they're going to be
able do a lot of things to help them out
um quite frankly when we had involvement
with them with family members in
California we expected a lot out of them
we expected too much um even though it
was a regulated profession there in
California um they did not add to the
situation and they delayed the ability
to get more appropriate care for a loved
one um because there was an expectation
that they were providing care and help
that they were not um I'm very concerned
for our elderly residents if they think
that this is somebody who's going to
come in and be able to do things that um
really should be in a licensed regulated
Health worker especially in their home
especially with vulnerable populations
and um further when we look at this we
see that this is creating something
that's on par with opthamol dispensing
which is the design verification and
delivery to the intended wearer of
lenses frames and other specially
fabricated optical devices based on a
prescription
that's a big jump going from the person
which is a very important skill to make
sure that somebody's glasses are correct
and their contact lenses are correct to
being that trusted person in somebody's
home that they rely on as their contact
to the health system um I think that
this is this is something that will
touch our most vulnerable people and I
think that moving through with this
where we even have questions on how to
regulate it how to deal with it is too
too much um there had been a question of
in my mind should we interim study this
so we can work through it but this is
such a large and complex thing that it
would be even hard for this committee to
meet in um the remaining time and in the
fall in order to come with an approach I
think we'd be doing it a disservice to
try and do this I think that it's
something that we need uh people to work
outside of the legislative process and
try and understand this better get
groups together try and figure out
specifically what's been needed look to
what's worked in other states look to
how people in California have been
misled because they thought they were
getting a health worker but they weren't
and make sure that we don't repeat the
stakes the mistakes of other states so
while I'm very compassionate to the idea
that and the recognition that community
health workers do do a lot of good um I
think that this
professionalization without the
underpinnings does a disservice overall
and I don't want to I don't want to
demean anything that people in the
community health workers are doing I
just want to make sure that we're not
putting false hope to our vulnerable
people thank you other discussion
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair I do concern
myself with one aspect that maybe was
talked about with the hearing I
apologize to the Comm committee for not
being
here we talked about in Senate Bill 495
the issue of abuse so I think there's
two parts to it that I concern myself
one is the competency of the person
doing it the other thing is ensuring
that the people that they're providing
the service to are not being abused
financially physically or otherwise and
I think that's one of the concerns I
have here is that if we do go forward
it's voluntary which makes sense but I
don't want that certification to be held
up to a patient or to somebody else
thinking that's a gold seal of approval
and they let the guard down and all of a
sudden we open them up the possibility
of abuse again Financial physical or
otherwise so that's one of Deep concerns
I have the way this bill's
written representative Palmer you had
sorry
um so I have representative T is next
first oh okay um I have a couple of
issues one um I really don't like the
fact that so much is crammed into one
bill because there are other parts of
this bill that I think are extremely
important though I think um
the commission on Primary Care was
covered in HB 169 and I'm hoping that
that will go through regardless the
other one that um is really important is
the um nurse Practice Act statute trying
to get more coverage for
everything um as far as the community
health workers I I mean I agree that
this bill is hard to understand I would
just say that those people people have
existed um paid for by grants and other
institutions and are a really key part
of delivering healthc care well and we
somehow need to figure that piece out
and get it covered because it does in
the long run um make a big difference in
whether patients who are being
discharged from the hospital or just
have complex um medical problems
actually get the care that they need to
get um at
home but it's
problematic thank you representative T
sorry about
that thank you Mr chairman so community
health workers uh as representative
Palmer stated exist they've been with us
well they're internationally they exist
and are relied upon in the US at least
in New Hampshire for at least 15 or 20
years we've had Community Health worker
initiatives the problem has been they're
you know not sustained if they're Grant
funded programmatically here there
whatever um anatomic head of the
Manchester Health Department spoke a few
years ago and said we need an army of
community health workers to meet the
needs that our communities currently
have community health workers are lay
community members they are trusted
members of their Community that's why
they're effective it has nothing to do
with clinical knowledge they do not
pretend to be clinical providers what
they do is they connect people to
resources they help people identify
where to go for help how to get
connected um they meet people where they
are in community
maybe they sometimes go into the home
but it is a profession there are
Professional Standards and what this
certification process does is just do
what many Most states have done across
the country and it has been written with
the best practices recognized and
recommended from across the country
which is that it be voluntary and um
that there be an advisory entity and the
only thing that has to do with the opic
thing is the fact is is nothing except
the fact that they have some kind of
advisory structure that would mirror
what's being proposed here and so um I
the um Association for state and
territorial Health officials and many
other people have demonstrated that the
return on investment is easily at least
3 to one if not 15 to one there are low
wage workers that make a huge difference
in plugging the gaps in the health
system which we have all collectively
agreed is very problematic and um I know
of no instances of any chws being
anything but incredibly welcome and
valued by patients and community and
family members and would strongly urge
that we pass what has been worked on for
a very long time for by a very broad
range of stakeholders from all over the
state from the North Country to um you
know Health Providers to community
organizations to Public Health
departments um so that this can be a
sustained uh Workforce that is valued as
they you know should
be thank you representative Weber and
thank you um I agree with everything
that representative TZ said um I have a
couple of well I want to
emphasize that comparing this to a
different profession that is equally not
supervised by a board is a false
equivalent because they're just
different one of these things is not
like the other um I also want
to remind people that what we heard at
the hearing or what I thought I heard at
the hearing was the issue of keeping
people in this profession which is very
helpful and very useful and often
there's a grant and they have a job for
a year or two years and then the grant
ends the job ends the help ends so a
patient who has um had a good
relationship with the carer loses that
carer and um in addition the carer may
go somewhere else and may not have this
you know they may work at a a different
employment altogether and we lose that
caring and expertise so that was a
problem that led to this I also want to
caution
about relying on our own individual
family
situations uh to make
change to make U policy across the board
because um there are all kinds of
different situations in all kinds of
different states uh the one that my
family went through was an elderly Aunt
of mine who did not live in the same
state I did and was
unwilling uh and and
was well she just didn't live in the
same state that I did and uh was
horribly taken advantage of by
completely unregulated carers uh with
nobody looking over the shoulder or
taking into account what might have
happened at another house and therefore
shouldn't go to the next house in any
case I think that regulation in this
case is better than non-regulation so I
will be opposing the
itl thank you representative Lon um
thank you Mr chairman um and thank you
for the these different statements um
first I wanted to key on to
representative TZ speaking to um
community health workers as trusted
community members um I think that that's
very important but we also need to
understand some of those consequences of
trust and I want to key into what
representative Merchant said um so I'm
on the subcommittee on Alzheimer's
disease and other related dementia at
the last meeting the New Hampshire elder
abuse and financial exploitation unit
from the Attorney General's office gave
a presentation um in which you know you
know one in 10 older vict older adults
are victimized in each year with only
one in 24 reported um 60% of abuse and
neglect comes at the hands of family
members but where does that other 40%
come from caregiver neglect whether it's
family or not is the most common form of
neglect and only one in7 cases of
caregiver neglect are
reported so there is harm that is
happening in the state they're following
up on those resources we have elder
abuse and financial exploitation we have
a daughter-in-law that stole
$102,000 from a a family member with
with um early onset dementia and she was
convicted and sentenced we had a son
that sold
$325,000 from a parent that had lack
capacity because they had dementia with
Alzheimer's Tye and they spent 5 to 10
years in the state prison we had a
brother and sister-in-law that stole
$90,000 from a woman who had dementia
and at the time of the trial she was
deceased and those defendants spent a
year in the New Hampshire state prison
um this is something that is a concern
and is being worked on in the Attorney
General's office to make sure that we
are protecting our vulnerable adults um
our vulnerable senior citizens and given
that the reporting rate is so low and
given the rate the fact that we have
these Community workers already here
which is good but adding a whole another
layer to it by making it an
institutionalized process where um
people will say great we have this
they're licensed by the state I can
trust them that we already have
significant issues and I'm just
concerned about what's going to happen
to our elderly Granite Staters because
the information from the Attorney
General's office says that it is a
problem
here okay any other representative
Shapiro yes I'm going to vote against
itl um and I think this is an initiative
that's well worth us pursuing um it
speaks to two um issues that are brought
up here all the time time one is
Workforce
shortage
um three issues one is the general
dysfunction second one is the general
dysfunction of our
um provision of Medical Care in the
state and in the country and third the
issue of trust and I would just like to
distinguish you know my feeling about
the issue of trust from um the previous
speaker which is um there's been a lot
of talk about the public not trusting
the Health Care system in general and
not trust and we know there's been a lot
of um you know there's been a lot of
issues that that have come down from
covid which has um eroded trust in the
Health Care System um whether I think it
should or not it clearly has and I think
that the key aspect of the community
health workers is that there are people
who are in People's Community who people
can relate to um who may speak the same
language as them and I think this will
be an e this will be go a long way in
terms
of increasing the trust between the
Health Care System overall and
individuals who are being served and I
do acknowledge that people can be taken
advantage of and
um they can be taken advantage of by
physicians who are licensed by the board
they can be taken advantage of by um
relatives um
by the mailman who delivers mail so I
think that
um I think that the the advantages to
having people who people can really
relate to helping them with everyday
me trumps the danger which is already
which is already clearly there so I will
vote against itl and vote for hopefully
vote for or to pass on this bill
representative TZ did you you started to
put your microphone on but uh any other
discussion on uh oh yes representative
Murphy thank you it's it's a it's nice
to be able to push the red button here
um as you know I've been away for a
little bit of time and what you can
really do thank you but what you really
do is you notice in maybe you're a bit
more heightened uh awareness to what is
said um and I first came across
community health workers almost a decade
ago up in Plymouth New Hampshire and it
was impressive to me how they work
within the community they have the trust
of the community and during that past 10
years I've also seen the decline of the
the the trust necessarily in healthc
care providers so I've seen this group
of community healthcare workers have a
trust you know quotient go up while
Healthcare Providers has gone down to
some degree whether I agree with that or
not is another story altogether but what
I did hear when this bill was introduced
uh over the past couple of weeks was the
concepts of the social determinance of
health so what these people are doing
they're not going into your house and
prescribing medication they're making
sure that your electricity bill was paid
so that your insulin in the refrigerator
is on um they're arranging rides to you
know to get to appointments they are uh
basically helping with housing issues
they are helping with medication issues
they helping with getting a prescription
from CVS and I also heard a primary care
provider saying we need help and so if
there's any lack of trust in the primary
care providers offices in large part
it's because they can't get access to
these people whereas they can get access
to a community health worker so these
people need help it keeps them out of
their doctor's office it keeps them out
of the hospital which you know having
recently been there is very expensive
care um and so what I would say is that
yes the bill has a lot of you know
entanglements to it I appreciate the
amendment that was made because I think
that that does help it quite a bit um
but what I'm saying this is basically is
my experience with the um uh listening
and what I hear but also more
importantly what I saw with the
community health workers at a tertiary
Care Medical Center you know sometimes
you don't get into the weeds with what
happens at home but having worked at a
community hospital for the past 10 years
of my career you really become aware of
the value of the community health worker
and what they do to a family and what
they do for a patient so I will vote
against the itl I understand that the
bill may have a lot of complicating
factors to it but much of it I agree
with and the amendment only makes it
better so I will vote for hopefully what
will be an OTP um motion after this one
is thank you thank you any other
discussion representative
Nagel this is probably more of a comment
than anything but I just find this bill
kind of a sad statement of modern
society I mean my mother used to do this
when we were kids you know we lived in
ethnic and you know um neighborhoods and
churches and people just reached out and
made sure that you you had what you
needed you know you could recognize in a
second when somebody needed something
the problem is doesn't happen like it
used to and it makes all this almost a
necessity which I think is sad but it's
real and um I do have a gentleman in our
um nonprofit that does this he saved a
lot of people's lives and um he um you
know a guy walks on water to me um
totally uncertified really probably
shouldn't be doing what he's doing so
something that will Empower him means a
lot to me
thanks representative Merchant thank you
Mr
chair I want to follow up on what Dr
Nel's talking about one of the concerns
I have also even though this is
voluntary where it leads
to I want to be sure that people who
work in those Arenas that Dr Nel or
represent Nel talked about whether it be
from the church the community itself and
so forth
we don't somehow
inadvertently create a problem where
they can't do their job or help somebody
out because they don't have the
certification even though it's co
voluntary so then all of a sudden people
looking for and asking are you Vol are
you certified and the answer will
probably be no because it's not required
so therefore is the patient in the
quandry saying oh you're not competent
to do what you're doing so I really
wrestle with that in the marketplace and
saying it's one of those things where
you got the seal of approval that
somebody's looking for which is probably
not needed completely yet the patient's
looking at it and saying they're in a
quandry because at that point in time
I'm looking for the seal of approval yet
you don't have it but you can still do a
lot for me you come from the church you
come from other places if you will and
that's one of the things looking for
within the realm of the patients
particularly elderly patients they're
confused they need to have the ability
to get the assistance and help that they
need from trusted sources and not just
rely upon certification that's also in
conjunction with the ISU have with using
it as a shield to somebody who wants to
abuse an LLY patient physically or
financially so in saying that I will
support the
ideal representative TZ yeah thank
you I want to make it really clear these
are not caregivers these are not uh you
don't have a chw and a longitudinal
relationship
unless there's something else um going
on um there are two really
wellestablished Community Health worker
training programs that were modeled
after very long-standing effective
Community Health worker training
programs in other states um those um
there are hundreds of people who've gone
through the programs they get trained
maybe they get hired for a job and then
the funding runs out and then they can't
continue in that professional role which
is really really valued it is at the
doctor's office maybe realize the
primary reason a patient is struggling
is because of their food insecurity but
the doctor's office is not equipped to
address that but maybe they then make a
call to a community agency or maybe they
have a chw in the office or a
partnership so that somehow or other
someone in this role whether or not
they're doesn't matter where they're
stationed like who they're who's giving
them their paycheck but somewh how or
other someone who's whose expertise is
to help address their primary needs get
them connected to resource es so they
can be um healthier uh is Avail is you
know their being available is really
valuable um and there's something else
you said that slipped my mind um and and
and and uh there are you know there's a
whole set of um work that's been done
across the country to have established
competencies to have you know
recognized uh qualifications and so the
reason this is voluntary is because our
people have been doing this work for 20
years and um we let the chws tell us
whether or not they wanted to move
forward with certification over the last
at least 5 years there are people for
whom saying well you have to be
certified maybe for certain kinds of
compensation and so that's why we're
ending up with the bill that is
presenting this as an Avenue for certain
things like maybe U reimbursement by
certain mechanisms uh but the
certification in and of itself isn't
necessarily going to change someone's
rate of pay right it'll just be an
additional credential but some people
have 20 years of experience and and
Goodwill that they've garnered and
that's enough of a credential so that is
why it's voluntary and the kinds of
concerns that are being raised are are
handled by other presses like you get
other kinds of training if you're
working with Elders or working out of a
Elder Social Service Agency right
there's additional competencies and
education and credentials that can be
provided representative Weber thank you
and I just I just come back to two
fundamental principles because I hear
the concern that everybody has for for
elders and not being um taken advantage
of and those are all very real and very
concerning issues that happen right now
and so it seems to me that establishing
more accountability
not leaving things the way they are is a
good thing for number one and number two
encouraging this Workforce which we all
agree is
necessary uh is another good thing and
that's why I'm going to vote against the
itl thank you representative Shapero yes
just in in regard to um
the opportunity for people to take
advantage of other people I think um yes
these people would not be attached to a
board and maybe at some point that would
be a good idea um
but from the discussion it sounds almost
like we're assuming that these people
will be operating as independent agents
and going into people's homes but
there'll be other guard rails all these
people will be working for organizations
um that have
um you know that have um policies that
have
supervision people will be working as
parts of teams so I think that while I
understand the the concern about people
taking advantage of other people which
obviously um we heard a lot of examples
of how that happens with a variety of
people um it's not like these people
will be independent agents going into
people's homes um free to take advantage
of people they'll be working um under
supervision as part of an
organization representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman um I just wanted to
bring up two things um my question would
be whether these groups that they're
working for are regulated by the state
because we ran into the challenge with
the sober homes having people that had
an administrative role not having
accountability for what was done so if
there's not similar accountability
through whoever is employing the
community health workers we're just
creating another area where people think
that there are safeguards in place that
may not exist um the other is there's
confusion over this representative TZ
seems is a subject matter expert in this
as far as I'm concerned and she had
stated that this is not longitudinal
care yet representative Weber was
talking about the importance of of uh
people in this role continuing to see
individuals that they already have a
relationship with I know that it can
have different situations and different
scenarios but um my question too is is
we want to encourage people to be
involved in the healthcare Workforce
maybe there's a reason that as a grant
goes away we bring people into into
stepping up another level of care so
that they can they can join the
workforce um and provide even greater
levels of care if they're so interested
so I I think that while it's well
intentioned I just don't think that's
this is ready for prime time at all
thank you all right we've covered it
pretty well anybody got anything
new seeing seeing no one else um motion
is um in expedient to legislate on
Senate Bill 403 FN I'll ask the clerk to
call all representative Lan yes
representative ner
yes CLK votes yes representative kofalt
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes represent
resentative Nagel
no representative pelosof
yes representative Weber
no representative McKay
no Representative fedus
no representative Canon
no representative Nutter upam no
representative Shapiro no representative
Merchant
yes representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no Representative
tez
no and representative McDonald yes 10 to
10 okay do I have another
me okay who U representative or
representative TZ I'll defer to
representative T motion to pass as
amended okay um okay represent TZ moves
on and I will second okay representative
Weber seconds any other discussion or do
you want to speak to your motions I
think we've covered it but
representative taes you have anything
additional or okay all right I'll ask
collect to call the RO motion is out to
pass as amended on Senate Bill 403
FN representative Lon
no representative ner no clerk votes no
Representative kofalt no
Representative mlan
no representative Seth King no
representative Missour no representative
Nagel yes representative POF
no representative Weber yes
representative K yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes represent
TZ yes and represent McDonald no 10 to
10 okay other another one that will go
to the floor without
recommendation next up is Senate Bill
409 FN and representative Weber I know
you have an amendment for that thank you
Mr chairman I've got to shovel through
my piles here for a
moment
uh they went around that are there
extras that went around that
way they're still they're still being
passed out yeah they did pass here
I think there's more over
there if you have still three that I
okay no be two reports on each because
it's
representative Weber do you want to make
a motion yes please I'd like to uh move
the adoption of amendment 2024 1563 H
and I'd like to speak to that if I might
is there a second to the motion second
representative not oh representative uh
Merchant I'm sorry seconds everybody's
hand went up at once representative
rubia recognize to speak to your motion
thank you
um you remember when this bill came to
us it had a list of about five things
and it said in the text that all five of
them had to be present uh for Medicaid
reimbursement to happen so um I made
several changes mostly I kept those
things the same but I rearranged the
wording uh the
first
the first change that I made to what was
given to us comes on line
1112 and I made it specific that
providers shall be me eligible for
Medicaid reimbursement when the provider
has documented the following because I
know there were concerns about
documentation and I didn't want to make
that too uh narrow and I certainly know
that Medicaid has a lot of documentation
anyway but I want to be sure it is docu
mented so that's just in there so on
line 13 it's required that the response
originated through an emergency call
which is a little broader than 911 but
still keeps the issue of this is not in
connection with a transport between
facilities or something it's an
emergency call um in all cases the
patient has to have consented to
evaluation and treatment and then one of
the following only one one of the
following three things has to
happen either a after the evaluation and
when indicated treatment the paramedic
or EMT and the patient agrees there's no
need for transportation that's number
one and in all of these cases I mean
Services have to be rendered because you
can't bill for them unless services are
rendered so it doesn't say that again
and again but that's a requirement
that's already required by Medicaid
secondly the patient does not estest and
actually refuse actively refuses
transport to an emergency room for
evaluation so that would be when the
patient and the uh EMT disagree on the
need for transport but the patient has a
right not to be transported it doesn't
mean they haven't been evaluated and
treated um and see the patient this is a
combination of two in the original Bill
and it says the patient is stable for
referral to uh physician other community
source and the patient has the ability
including mental capacity and
transportation assist resources to
obtain assistance and medically
indicated followup so um you know they
have a plan and the plan is capable of
being followed out um so one of those
three a b or c has to happen and then we
had the issue of reimbursement after um
assistance had treatment had been given
but was unsuccessful uccessful and the
patient did not U was not resuscitated
so uh the last part says they shall
providers shall also be eligible for
Medicaid reimbursement when the provider
has documented that the response
originated through an emergency call
resuscitation efforts were terminated
and the patient is deceased because you
can't have any consent under those under
those conditions so I hope that that
will meet with your approval thank
you representative Merchant thank you
represent Weber uh thank you Mr chair in
regards to resusitation efforts were
terminated so it's just basically at
that point in time the efforts to
resuscitate somebody could be terminated
because they were resuscitated but the
patient didn't become deceased is that
when I'm reading it be clear well it
says when the provider has documented
first of all the response originated
through an emergency
call resuscitation efforts were
terminated and the patient is deceased
is it all three of those yeah I would
think so and
certainly
unless I'm remembering
[Music]
certain issues with people with DNR at
home orders and I can't remember the
name for that
but my
understanding is that unless there is if
there is a need for
resuscitation the EMTs will do that
unless there is some kind of P it's a
pulst or other order saying that they're
not going to thank
you other disc representative
kofo um thank you so I I guess
I'm I'm just wondering if a a technical
adjustment might be required ired
um many many years ago I actually was a
certified EMT in Massachusetts and
recall being called to a uh a home where
the patient was deceased when we
arrived um I think that this is actually
a fairly common scenario and so um my
question is whether or not we need to
adjust the
language
um to to say if if resuscitation was
terminated if initiated um again this I
may be nitpicking here but I would think
that if if emergency services are called
to respond um and the idea is that they
ought to be reimbursed for that whether
the patient is deceased when they arrive
or sometime shortly after they arrive uh
should not affect the material outcome
I can't guarantee it because what I did
was I took two Clauses which were
dangling off of other things and put
them
together uh but I
think I mean first of all if you walk in
and you have determined that the patient
is deceased and that resuscitation
efforts are not going to be
availing under whatever those
circumstances are so I'm not going to
speculate then you haven't started
treatment and um there may have been an
evaluation uh but I'm pretty sure that
the underlying Medicaid regulations
about what you can bill for will cover
this but I can't promise that um and if
somebody wanted to come up with a floor
Amendment where the drafting was more
Artful I certainly would be glad to at
least consider that
um but I am very much
hoping that
we not in this case make the perfect the
enemy of the good because it is a big
problem that this will help a lot and we
can certainly revisit it as soon as next
year other
discussion representative Seth King and
then representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to to thank uh
representative Weber for um I think
vastly improving the logic of the code
here it scratches that itch of mine so
it's it's very nice um but I do think um
representative Kofa brings up a good
point in that there are a lot of people
um who will be resuscitated um right
then and there and still actively refuse
to go to a hospital that does happen
quite a bit my understanding is
especially with people that overdose
they don't want to go to a hospital so
that could that could um Encompass quite
a few people something to think about
representative Weber and in that case um
they the people who did the
resuscitation would be compensated
because you're not under that last piece
I just wanted to make it clear that in
that case they would receive you know
they can bill for the um treatment that
they
gave and that's
scenario um B
that's covered here representative
Murphy no I was thank you Mr chairman I
was just going to say that you know in
section
A you know to representative kof's
question you know if um there's an
evaluation and the patient is deceased
then they should be compensated for that
so basically you know they have done an
evaluation it's not an easy thing always
to determine you know deceased versus
not but if they did an evaluation and
the patient is Cold Stone dead then and
that's an evaluation that they've done
and should be compensated for that so I
would hope that that is addressed in
that
language representative kofalt so I I
think we have um there there's
sufficient comment at this point that
there at Le is at least some legislative
intent in that direction
um perhaps I will reach out um in the
coming week or so to somebody in in the
department to determine whether or not
this would be reimbursable given the
current language and then if anybody is
interested in uh potentially bringing a
floor Amendment with me uh to address
that I would invite you to do so thank
discussion taking no other discussion so
the motion is out to pass on um
Amendment U 2024 hyphen 1563 H to Senate
bill for 9 FN Mr chair yes do we have to
vote on the amendment first yeah that
that's the mo to pass on pass the
amendment representive Leon yes
representive ner yes clerk votes
yes K representative kofalt
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative pza yes
representative Weber
yes representative M yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ yes
represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay Amendment passes 20 to Zer
representative Weber I was going to say
I would ask that we put it on the
consent calendar with the understanding
that if an amendment is to be
forthcoming I if if if an amendment
actually is there uh I would be glad to
join with others and making up the 10
people to take it off consent um it has
a million dollar I'm sorry I do that all
the time representative Weber so you
make me feel good my
apologies thank you representative Miss
I do that all the time so thank you for
doing it representative Weber make me
feel better uh do you have a motion
representative Weber uh well I guess I
do I would like to move a to passes
amended okay is there a second
representative not up from
seconds uh any other discussion do you
wish to speak to that motion
representative Weber or no thank you I I
think we've we've done that enough any
other discussion on this motion
representative Paz off and then
King I I like the intent of this bill to
reimburse for unfunded uh mandates but I
think it goes from the wrong direction
we need to which uh which those unfunded
mandates and
um uh as as we just heard like we are
not clear what exactly this bill is a
man that will be covering so it's hard
to evaluate uh how expensive it will be
and it looks like it will be expensive
uh and we don't know how much it will
potentially save so I think it's not
ready for prime time so even though I
like
intent I will vote no thank you
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair so I'm going to be reluctantly
voting no on this bill um I understand
all the reasons why somebody would vote
for this bill I think there's a lot of
um good cases to be made for it but my
issue um is a little different um and
that is that we heard in testimony that
um several states have already done this
and the way I see it is that when it
comes to grabbing for federal dollars
it's kind of like playing Hungry Hungry
Hippos that if you decide to be a state
that doesn't want to participate in the
game you're going to lose all the
marbles and the other states that do
participate will get those federal
dollars so it really is only a matter of
time before all the states join on and
do this um but the problem I have is
that I think a lot of people don't
really realize how it's being paid for
we say oh well instead of paying it for
local taxes we're paying it with federal
taxes but in reality we're not paying it
in federal taxes because most people
don't understand that 2third of all the
dollars in existence are outside of the
United States and when the federal
government runs a deficit they print
dollars out of thin air to pay for these
bills so what we're effectively doing is
we are inflating the currency we're
destroying the value of it and people
that live in countries all around the
world including poor people they're
seeing the value of the dollars that
they hold lose value and so what we're
really doing is we are charging people
in poor countries to pay for the welfare
in a rich country and I think that is
totally immoral I don't support it I
understand why it all makes sense on
paper um and I don't think there's
anything I can do to stop it because our
appetite for federal dollars is
insatiable um that being said um I don't
feel like talking about this on the
house floor so if it I I'm willing to do
consent calendar I'm not terribly
opposed to the bill it's it's small
potatoes compared to all the things we
blow our money on but it's it's the
principle that really bothers me thank
you representative mlan and then
representative
Merchant yeah uh yeah thank you Mr chair
I mean I I think it's immoral to to
mandate somebody come out and provide a
service and not pay them so I I think
that you know they're providing a
valuable service they need to be
compensated for that it's not right that
you mandate somebody to do something and
that you not compensate them and I
understand the concern about the dollars
but there was also some discussion in
the work session where another benefit
of this is the opportunity to go out
there do an assessment render immediate
care and keep people in their home and
maybe prevent them having to go to the
hospital in the first place so I think
um you know uh we're going to have two
bites at the Apple because the house
bill passed and so I'm going to be
supporting the Bill thank you Mr chair
representative Merchant then
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chair following up on representative
Clan's comments um I do concur to have
something mandated and not pay for it is
an unfunded mandate um that's
fundamentally concern number two is that
when it's unfunded and it's a mandate it
falls down to the local property
taxpayer and we have property taxpayers
are struggling in our state to continue
to downshift responsibility from the
state who mandates this or the federal
government that mandates it and not
support a local property tax base I
think is
unconscionable representative
Shapiro thank you Mr
chair I've never never played Hungry
Hippos so um but I'd be glad to try it
if you wrote it in
um I I appreciate representative your
principled stand but I think probably
what you're saying is the same could be
said about any federal money that we
accept and um pay for and I certainly um
do have a philosophy of government um
providing a broad safety net for people
so I will support the bill I also have a
question for the chair which is
um whether this actually can go on the
consent calendar because there is no
appropriation in the bill I had written
a um an amendment with an appropriation
but I have not introduce that so
currently there's no appropriation that
would have to be done by the finance
committee or they would have to extend
the um date at which the bill took
effect um so my question really is can
we put it on the um consent calendar
since currently there's no appropriation
in the bill there is a the fiscal note
which says an approximate amount of
money that it would
cost thank you representative we you
would know better than I but I would
think it could go on if if if depending
on how the vot different speakers have
had different rules so I am um loath to
utter what is might be a definitive
opinion um my understanding in the past
was that if it didn't have an actual
appropriation it didn't have to go on
the consent calendar and the other thing
is this bill is going to go to finance
so it's not like it's the last word but
I don't care about the consent calendar
if we could just vote on the bill and
get on to the other five that we have
representative
TZ thank you Mr chairman I just want to
remind us that we had an incredible
outpouring of um people present uh uh
showing their commitment every single
time we have touched this bill and I
think the principle underlying the need
for it is um in addition to all the good
points that have been made previously
is when we need to call 911 for
ourselves or our mother it doesn't
matter who's paying the bill if that
emergency uh service provider does no
longer exist because they went out of
business it doesn't matter if we have
gold star health insurance of our own
like that will not be available so this
is a public good that we need to be able
to assure continues to exist in this
state and I I don't see why we're not
all in agreement on
that representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman and again you know for fear
that we would uh derail where we're
heading for not a pass with an amendment
um what I wondered about and what I
thought about when I was watching and
you can't really scream through the
camera
that is in front of you all but having
said that one of the questions I had and
I still have is why the regulations for
the repayment for that one patient that
switched from Medicare or from Medicare
when was on Medicaid why couldn't they
have the same regulation as for
reimbursement that is um the same
regulation that the Medicare patient has
so that that's more of a question than
it was and I don't want to do rail where
we're going right now but one of my
questions was always you know why do we
have why why couldn't the same
regulatory you know um mandates for
Medicaid be the same as for
Medicare with just the fact that we
accept a smaller reimbursement which we
know anyway so that was more of a
question than it was a um or a statement
than it is a true question so I don't
want to derail where we're going but
again that was always my question that I
had from the get-go thank thank
you there no other hands up no other
questions let's proceed to the vote the
motion is ought to pass as amended on
Senate Bill 409 FN I'll ask the clerk to
call the RO representative Leon
yes representative ner yes clerk votes
yes representative cofal
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missour
yes representive
Nagel representive POF
no representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes represent Murphy
yes represent Palmer yes representative
tez yes representative McDonald yes
18-2 okay is there any objection to
consent no seeing none so we will put up
that on the consent calendar then all
right next up is a Senate Bill uh 455 FN
representative Nagel did you have a
motion
okay that was my question earlier
representative palaza do you want to
motion I move to interim
study on Senate Bill uh 455 FN 55 FN
there a
second I'll
second um representative Paz off do you
motion if not I mean that's fine it's up
to you
just um this
issue needs more study because there
were some conflicting numbers during
testimony so while it's an important
issue I think we need to study it
more thank you representative
Weber I'm going to get vote against
interm study because it seems to me that
the
policy the underlying
policy is a good one we want people to
be reimbursed for services to people who
need
Prosthetics and this bill is a second
committee bill it's going to
finance and so the
underlying policy which is I want people
to have the devices that they need to
live their fullest lives and I want the
people people who make those devices to
be reimbursed to the best of our ability
to do it which is not going to be as
much as they should be reimbursed in any
case so I hope that people will defeat
the interim study so a motion of ought
to pass may be made so that this can go
on to finance and they can decide
whether it's something that we can
afford or not representative Nagel thank
you Mr chairman um this bill is really
important to me I've been involved in
this discussion for a very long time and
the best thing that came out of that
hearing was that the testimony was given
by an independent
organization um beginning 30 40 years
ago the concept of an independent vendor
being able to do this was like because
of Medicaid payments was like
non-existent that the fact that these
guys even still existed just totally
blew me away um what bothered me even
more was the number of vendors we have
in the state and how few are we're
talking about a group of people that
deal with a very traditional historic
Medicaid population as a large part of
their their payer base um these are the
people with disabilities that are not
going to be competitively employed um
many of them have cognitive disabilities
and addition to their physical
disabilities so they're people that
really rely on the state for survival
and with these braces and and I don't we
can't ignore the orthotic part of it cuz
building an orthotic is an art form
um that that I kind of think they
trivialized during the discussion but
you know Prosthetics and Orthodox is
really important but it allows these
people to function to get into the
community to have a meaningful life um
they are not getting the blades that um
you know the the Olympians are getting
which is kind of sad in a way but you
know they're doing the best they can for
these people um one of the things that
was bothers me a lot is like in a
prosthetic development like when you
have an amputation the way we did it
when I started out murf you may or may
not remember this but we did immediate
posttop fitting so that the person woke
up with a leg on their on their their
leg and they um you know there's a lot
of reasons why I did it there were both
medical and psychological and social but
at the same point they don't there's no
way in hou hockey sticks that I decided
to not swear that you can do that on
Medicaid because it's a bundled payment
and everything that you do costs you
money in the end so we're not providing
the service that people need now and
this allows them to stay in business to
stay in function and the last thing I
will point out is that these guys
everybody needs an easy Bill to get
through really
quick everybody needs an easy thing in
work that this is makes your job a
little bit quicker for at least 10
minutes these guys used to do a lot of
off-the-shelf orthotic fits guess who
took that from them my group other
groups things like that now we do the
fitting we get the money and when what
we do is we delegate Medicaid to these
guys so they have to give the braces
that don't generate any Revenue because
nobody else does it and he said it right
to us that if this they're going to make
a vote within the next year whe they're
going to accept Medicaid anymore and
that's not good that's bad and and I
really think that it's important we
support this Bill thank you other
discussion representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair I definitely want to oppose
the interim study I believe there a
couple things that I would focus my
attention on I will be focusing my
attention on one is that it's something
that's desperately needed from a certain
part of our population that itself is
vulnerable to many things but looking at
it from a financial point of view from
the state itself the best way to get
somebody off from Medicaid is for them
to get back to work and if you don't
have the appropriate prosthetic devices
to help the person be become gainfully
employed they remain on the state
coffers because that's where they have
to be because they don't have the
opportunity to become gainfully employed
so as a self-interest from the state
itself looking at strictly from a
financial point of view the more we can
do to help people to get out of the
Medicaid system and into full employment
I think it serves us all at the end
appropriately representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and um in
reference to representative Nel's
question it was used we used to call it
an IOP because it was immediate
post-operative you know prosthesis that
we would put on patients but having said
that you know it was interesting because
it was probably only within the last
week they had one of the Prosthetics and
Orthotics folks from New Hampshire down
the SE Coast I believe it was that
talked about this there are only five in
the state that do uh these processes in
orthotic management and they basically
lose every time that they put one of
these on for a patient with Medicaid so
they said well why would you charge
anything anyway well because something
is better than nothing and it over
offsets some of the cost that they have
elsewhere in their business so the long
story short was that they did give
examples of people that actually would
be able to return to the workforce were
able to take care of themselves were
able to take care of their family uh if
they were able to be mobile so uh I
would vote against the uh interim study
and hope that a different motion would
be um uh proposed representative Lon um
thank you Mr chairman um I actually
wrote my College admission essay about
making a prosthetic that could return a
concert violinist uh performing so
Prosthetics there's definitely something
that I have a big interest in um one of
the things that I did here was that
sometimes the reimbursement is higher
than that 90% of Medicaid which is one
of the reasons why I'm going to support
the interim study but if that fails I'm
also um going to be supporting the bill
because I think that we don't want to
cut short the ability to pay for it at a
higher rate either so thank you other
discussion representative mlan just
clarification um I thought that this
bill just moved it from 80% to 90% so
would that is that a real concern
um so again I'm just asking for
clarification because it would obviously
the original Bill asked for 100% And
then it was amended down to 90% but I
don't personally think they get I mean
the rule of thumb on Medicaid's 10 cents
on the dollar
yeah so my understanding 30 cents on the
dollar my understanding was that it was
at least 80% um this is my understanding
but I don't think the interim study
motion is going to pass but my
understanding is that it's at least 80%
but this says equal to 90% of the
that's my understanding of
Medicare any other discussion or any
other
questions seeing none uh the motion is
inim study on Senate Bill 455 FN I'll
ask the clerk to call of representive
Lan yes representive ner yes
clerk votes no representative kofalt
yes Representative
mlan
no representative Seth King
yes representative Nagel
no representative POF
representative McKay
no Representative fedus
no representative Canon
no representative Nutter upam
no representative Shapiro no
representive Merchant
no representative
Murphy
no representative Palmer
no Representative tez no
and represent McDonald
to13 fail 7 to 13 7 to
13 okay motion fails for interim study
is there another
motion representative Nagel um ought to
pass please second representative Nagel
moves ought to pass and representative
Weber seconds uh do either wish either
of you wish to speak to your motion or
are we all set
okay and the motion is out to pass on
any other
discussion saying none the motion is out
to pass on Senate Bill 4555
FN when the clerk is ready I'd ask him
to call the
rooll representative Lon yes
representative ner yes clerk votes yes
Representative kofalt
no representative mlan yes
representative Seth King
no representative Missour
yes representative Nel yes
representative POF
no representative Weber
yes representative K
yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon yes representative
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative TZ
yes and representative McDonald yes
17-3 motion passes
17-3 uh representative do we need a
Minority Report on something like that
or it doesn't matter if they want to
write one they have the option p no no
Minority Report okay thank
you 17 to3 thank you is it Mr chairman
is it possible to go on consent even
though it's 173 if there's no objections
to it is
it I if there's no objection leave that
up
to does anyone does anyone object to a
consent okay all right we'll we'll try
we'll put it on consent and see if it
gets
rejected okay thank you uh next up is is
motion relative to the state be uh loan
repayment program for qualified nursing
professionals and making an
appropriation
therefore representative Shapiro I move
a to pass representative Shapiro moves
out to pass is there a
second representative Weber seconds
representative Shapiro you want to speak
to your
motion yes I think this um bill as it
was explained during the hearing is
um a a very moderate expansion of the
slurp program the student loan repayment
program for medical
providers and um it just adds
$300,000 specifically for nurses with
um I
mean it's money it's $300,000 but in in
my mind that's a a pretty moderate
expansion of a program that's meant to
um enhance Workforce specifically in an
area that has become particularly
problematic which is Nurses which um and
and and we've talked a lot about how um
there are so many nursing agents nurses
that are providing care in variety of
places especially nursing homes um which
just UPS the cost um for our County
nursing homes and other nursing homes so
I think this is a an effort to remedy
that by helping students with large um
student loans thank you other
discussion representative Murphy uh
thank you Mr chairman and um one of the
things I came to realize was that uh
it's not just the Community Hospitals
it's at the major medical centers that
nearly 80% right now near 80% of the
nurse Force at DH right now is Travelers
that's a very expensive ticket to pay
for you know on a regular basis um and
so what I'm saying is that what what
we've also realized too in training
programs is that if somebody moves here
and stays here and starts to work here
will stay here so I think it will help
the the nursing homes the Community
Hospitals but also the tertiary and
quary Care Medical Centers thank you
thank you representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman um and uh just looking
from my economic background and working
with companies that sought Financial
opportunities and then moved as a
temporary benefit left I appreciate the
the goal of trying to do this but I'm
not sure that somebody who's moving for
a temporary Financial benefit won't then
move for another temporary Financial
benefit um quite frankly when you look
at the economic incentives it makes
sense for a New Hampshire nurse to be a
travel nurse elsewhere and people from
other states to come here so my concern
is just continuing to further muddy
muddy the waters with additional money
here money there and just as a
policy-wise I don't think that um I
think that we're just compounding the
problem more and more so while I
appreciate the burden of this debt I
appreciate how challenging it is to be
here I just don't think that it's the
right solution
other
discussion representative kofalt then
representative
Merchant uh thank you Mr chairman so I I
guess you know my concern is you know
although it is a a limited amount of
money it is nevertheless consuming
taxpayer dollars um I I think we've seen
similar concerns on a national level
when we have taxpayers at large often
including people who never had
opportunity to Avail themselves of
higher education could not afford higher
education um subsidizing the higher
education of those who could um I I
don't think that's right I think what
we're doing is we're we're trying to uh
Tinker with um a a problem that is
driven by the fundamental economics um a
you if if the economics are broken um I
I
think trying trying to insert uh a
Band-Aid into that situation that um
really doesn't fix the problem on any on
any scale um is the wrong approach so
I'm going to be voting against uh this
OTP motion representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair I concur
with representative Cal in the sense
that um the economic supply and demand
however also look at it from Another
Side and that is particularly in the
County nursing homes that we subsidize
heavily from the state
coffers that if they're having to pay
more for traveling
nurses ultimately we're paying for it
anyways so at this point in time it's an
opportunity for us because there a
report required to find out how well
this program actually worked it's more
of a pilot to begin to understand in
fact by doing an incentive to people to
come to the state of New Hampshire to
work here does it in fact help us with
the economics because if we don't find a
way to reduce the labor cost in
particularly nursing homes we ultimately
pay the price when I say we I'm talking
about the state coers itself it's coming
out of our state budget so one way or
the other either we're going to pay for
it because it's coming out of the
request from the counties to the state
itself for more dollars to support their
deficits or we find a way to reduce the
burden because labor pool becomes
greater to drive the labor cost down so
I'll look at it stly from that point of
view thank you represent shapo thank you
Mr chairman I I think we all um are
guilty of using hyperbole you know once
in a while to prove our point but um so
it would be crazy for me to say that
this is going to solve the workforce um
problem with nurses I mean we I think we
could all agree that this
is if anything it will barely make a
dent um but I personally was moved by
talking to Christine Stoddard who
represents the qualified
um Health Centers um and the degree to
which they take advantage of the student
loan repayment program that the state um
runs um to keep people in jobs that are
probably not the most high-paying
nursing jobs and so I just think we
should do our part to add to that effort
um it's not it's not going to bring all
the nurses running to New Hampshire
other yes representative
TZ uh thank you Mr chairman I think um
without arguing about how economics
actually plays out in real life I I
think this is needed it's needed by um
the
employers um State loaner payment is a
very proven uh strategy that's used all
over the country
to put providers of healthare in places
where it's needed so similar to the
ambulance bill we just discussed There
Are Places rural New Hampshire other
places that are high need so people of
low economic means can have access to
health care access to healthcare then
helps you uh access better education and
better better employment opportunities
so um thinking about this investment
which is very modest and which is being
requested because of the need that's
already been established and proven um
uh makes a lot of sense thank you other
discussion representative Lon and then
representative mlan uh thank you Mr
chairman um economics isn't just
something that's thought about in Ivory
Towers it's something that impacts Our
Lives day-to-day um and especially as
state legislators we need to understand
how to best allocate our limited
resources many of us supported the
ambulance bill because it is absolutely
crucial to make sure that our first resp
responders are paid for providing these
vital services that we require them to
do and that quite frankly we count on
them to do um this bill it may or may
not attract people we've said that it
probably won't make much of a difference
we are looking at revenues that are
going down from the state because it
looks like the market you know I feel
like I'm on a roller coaster I'm
starting to look it looks like the
economy is probably heading back down
again I know that some people say that's
a reason for more subsidies but the
other question is where do we bring the
money from
do we want to then defund um the these
payments that we're having for these
non-transport calls is there something
else that we're not going to pay for in
exchange for the loan the student the
student loan repayment for nurses you
know we're to be stewards I know
recognize that we're not the finance
committee but giving an idea of which
policy we think is going to have a
greater impact to granted Staters
matters too I know that I believe that
the ambulance bill has a far greater
impact to Granite Staters then um
something that will be a nice to have
that may keep a few more nurses in
practice but that isn't going to move
the needle is significantly um and
that's why that's why if we're not going
to have people coming here for this if
it's something that um even if they do
come it's because they're chasing the
largest opportunity and I'm an economist
I'm a market person I don't have a
problem with chasing opportunity and my
idea is that hopefully people will find
their way here and just like me say wow
I finally found home um and my hope is
that we'll have people that come here
and say wow I finally found home but I'm
not certain that loan repayment is going
to be that segment you know the more
that we we respect and honor the people
and make sure that their autonomy U
personal autonomy as healthc care
providers is respected the better as
well so um I I recognize why many people
on here think that it's important but I
think that we're better off putting that
money towards reimbursement for non-
transport than for this that um doesn't
seem like it'll help and it may provide
some um incorrect influences
representative mlan and then
representative pmer thank you Mr chair I
mean I I I support the intention of this
bill but as was alluded to earlier
realistically it's not going to do
anything and with money in limited
Supply why would we give it if we don't
think it's going to in achieve the
desired intention the the fact of the
matter is there is such a huge dollar
difference between what the traveler is
paid and and what the regular person is
paid that is what you're going to have
to look at and that's what you're going
to have to do with respect to your pay
structure and that's a much harder
decision and and much more difficult
solution for hospitals to drive towards
and I have a lot of Sympathy For That in
in in an area of rising Healthcare costs
but that's what it's going to take we
had somebody alluded to discussions at
the county level we talked about the
same thing at Hillsboro County for
retention bonuses for uh the uh the the
deputies with the county sheriff it was
a $3,000 retention bonus but the
Manchester police are poaching them and
they're giving them $30,000 more and so
my heart says yeah but is it going to
achieve the the desired effect and with
money being what it is
um we need to have people looking at the
real solutions not the feel-good
Solutions in my opinion so I support the
intent but I can't support the bill
representative Palmer and then
representative Shapero so I guess um I'm
thinking this this is a short-term fix
and we're talking about the long-term
fix the short-term problem is um so
there was a nurse yesterday at work and
she took a job at the hospital I work at
in Vermont because Vermont has a pretty
good loan reimbursement program as
opposed to in New
Hampshire um good for us but the problem
the short-term problem is that we still
um have empty beds that we can't fill
because we don't have nurses I can't
send really sick patients to Dartmouth
because they don't have nurses and so
short term we need to sort of I my my
opinion on this is that we need to sort
of take any little bit we can get to
fill in plug a few holes the long-term
um Solutions are being looked at the
primary care Commission has got really
nice data to show that if we train more
nurses in New Hampshire they stay here
and that's that's that's the good
long-term solution and the same thing is
being applied to Physicians with new
residency programs in New Hampshire so I
don't think this is a great solution but
it but short term we need to do
something because we're we're you know
we're really struggling to take care of
patients representative
Shapiro yes uh maybe we've talked this
one through um see a few shaking heads
but I guess my my thought is that um
when people say this is just a Band-Aid
that that's that's code for this is not
useful but when you need a Band-Aid you
need a Band-Aid and I think this is a
Band-Aid but I think it's sometimes very
useful to have a Band-Aid and we
probably have different underlying
philosophical um philosophies about
these kind of things that will dictate
our vote but I'm going to vote for it
because I think it's a useful bandaid
representative Nel thank you Mr chairman
I I would Define this as more of an
orthotic than a Band-Aid but anyways oh
keep it pertinent um you know it's
really weird when we're going through
all these bills I'm looking at you know
this is a good idea this is a good idea
this is a good idea who's going to pay
for it who's going to pay for it who's
going to pay for it so I had a
conversation with somebody way smarter
than me and he told me it's not your
decision to make who's paying for it to
decide whether the the idea as value I I
I agree with everything that Dr Palmer
said um um continuity is unbelievably
important in healthcare and we don't
have it and travelers do not provide
continuity they're here today gone
tomorrow and there's a lot of people
that that we've seen you know nurses or
whatever that um you know with with
things like this will will'll choose to
stay and that's important and if you
have a nursing home like the counting
home or wherever you know your goal is
just to have at least a percentage of
people that stay and and this does help
and a lot of these entities actually do
subsidize education now on their own um
if I had to tell the finance department
and prioritize this relative to some of
the other things we've talked about this
would not be number one on my list with
that said that's their decision not mine
and that's why I'm going to support it
representative South King thank you Mr
chair um one thing that seems absent
from this conversation is where did all
the nurses go cuz you know just a few
years ago we didn't have this sort of
really bad nurse deficit and then
something happened and all of a sudden
we had a huge labor pool of nurses
leaving including my wife as a matter of
fact the nursing uh environment became
extremely hostile for like half of the
nurses and they just disappeared so you
might want to think about that if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
tell you right now that in order to even
I was looking at it a few years ago I
don't know if it's still the case but if
in order to even start the path of
becoming a new nurse
to go to school they were mandating
covid vaccines just to go to school so
not only have we alienated a huge
portion of nurses from the workforce
we've also alienated half of half of
this country who would otherwise think
about becoming nurses saying I'm not
going to take that stupid vaccine just
so I could go to school to become a
nurse and they're going to go do
something else so if you want to really
alleviate the
problem get rid of the thing that's
causing the problem don't just add
little Band-Aids to the situation thank
you representative I was just wondering
if we could move along to the vote okay
is there anything new anyone has
representative TZ I just want to add
that there's a lot of complexity to why
there's a nursing shortage in addition
to uh fifth of the workforce leaving as
a result of the pandemic and related um
feelings and attitudes um we it's
longstanding and that's why the
legislative Commission on the
interdisciplinary primer Workforce
exists and a whole other uh set of
people working on addressing these
Workforce issues that relate to supply
so that's why these strategies of um
loaner payment which have been proven to
be effective and which the employers are
requesting are um immediately helpful
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Seth King for bringing up one of the big
issues that we have here other states
successfully pushed back and allowed
their healthcare providers that wanted
to continue to care for patients to do
so with other Mr chairman I am going to
object to refighting the covid and
masking Wars in a context of a bill that
you may be for or you may be against but
which does not have anything to do with
that so given that we
have four to finish I ask that that be
ruled out of order representative land
point of order if somebody is to
interrupt aren't they supposed to ask
for a point of order and then be
recognized by the chair instead of just
speaking my apologies I should have done
that this is a and if I may continue
this is a causal Factor this is a causal
Factor where we had multiple healthc
care providers leaving we had people who
were not going to nursing school if we
think $300,000 in R loan repayment is
going to solve the problem we are
looking in the wrong place I have seen
certifications thanking um respit homes
places of Last Resort care thanking them
for having a vaccination rate of 75% yet
we had a zero tolerance policy in this
state and we are suffering for it we
have beds that are not filled because of
that we can't just sweep this under the
rug because this has caused harm it's
caused far more harm by requiring this
and pushing people out of the workforce
than um then a vaccine that did not show
point of order Mr chairman point of
order yes would you rule on my prior
point of order no matter how inartfully
stated I I I think this discussion I
think we've gone past the uh the debate
that's relevant for this bill and uh at
this point I think we're we're getting
into other issues so let let's just move
on I think everybody knows where
everybody stands on covid masks
um and and and and I'm not going to get
into the merits or the demerits of any
aspects of of the arguments but uh
representative Leon I respect what
you're saying and I understand your
points uh but clearly uh at this point
the mood of the room is is that we need
to move on and and why don't we do so
I'm going to ask the clerk to call the
all the motion is uh ought to pass on
Senate Bill 456 FN representative Leon
no representative ner no cler votes no
Representative kofalt
no Representative mlan no representative
Seth King no representative Missour no
representative
no representative Weber yes
representative M yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative tez yes and
representative McDonald
no uh 11 to
passes
okay all right I assume there'll be
Minority
Report representative Shapiro make
motion representative Le yes we'll fig
yes we'll figure that out okay there
will be a Minority Report I'm good ready
oh okay Bill Bill King has agreed to
write the representative King has agreed
to write the uh
Minority
Report okay so am I writing the report
oh you're writing the yes you're writing
the motion of the report on
OTP all right next up is Senate Bill 495
FN um and representative Weber you have
an amendment I believe I do I do have
Amendment um
1592 H which I will pass out and then I
would just be glad to have leave to
e
okay
okay representative Weber do you want to
make a motion um I would move the
2024-25 with the bill this addresses
some of them um I think we heard loud
and clear the need for some kind of
Regulation um and the concern that I had
personally was the definitions were a
little
circular uh but in fact the the initial
stuff that I objected to and in the
first part is existing language so I
don't want to mess with that CU I don't
want to m up what we may already be
doing in other contexts so this looks at
section Roman 2 which is the added
language and there were several
objections there one of which was we
weren't terribly sure what we were
talking about
secondly uh the residential treatment
was included and we were told that
residential treatment was not included
so what the the amendment makes clear is
that it does not apply to residential
treatment so that uh because that was
taken out and the other thing that was
omitted was the language about shall
include but not be limited to so uh the
door is not fully open the door is
limited to these items which
are as far as I know set out by the
American Society for Addictive medicine
so in that respect I think it makes it
clearer as to what we're talking about
and um that's where we're at other
discussion on the amendment I
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair apologies for my confus confusion
on this I'm I'm just not I'm just not
sure what's being changed in the
original bill it says amend RSA
172 but then in the original bill it
says amend RSA 126a and what just can
you just fill me in what part's being
don't well the origin the bill is
exactly as it was in the original if you
look at the original Bill the only thing
that this is changing in the
amendment is the definitional section
under two which is the
part that relates
to the the state substance use of
disorder Services System but that is
already existing language if you see in
the original bill as we received it that
is not in bold that is in statute now so
that already
exists this is an addition to existing
statute and so all it's doing is
changing the added definitional
section I'm sorry I'm looking at
Amendment to SB 495 FN I think I screwed
up because we're on Bill 496 now right
what are we doing
no my apologies it's line it's line 26
okay we've certainly done a lot to burn
up uh our energy this morning but um
representative
mlan uh thank you Mr chair and um I
guess I have a question for some of the
folks in the committee
um in the in the week since we we had
the public hearing I was very confused
probably had a lot of circular
questioning which probably confuse
everybody even more but I think I kind
of understand it now I did communicate
you know with the folks at Manchester
where obviously we have a real problem
and um substance abuse treatment in an
unregulated manner in the city is a real
problem speaking with the mayor last
night he said look this is the reality
the reality is you spend 90 days in
Valley Street stre jail you come out
you're clean you go in to get your
treatment and you're being treated by
someone who's been sober for 30 days and
everything kind of goes off the rails so
um I agree and I a th% support the
intent and the need of this and I
communicated that to the mayor my
concern was from what I was able to
gather out of the testimony last week
there was some real concerns with
respect to the breadth so not knowing a
lot about it to the extent of some of
the other folks those folks that had
objections about does this eat into AA
does this eat into the single shingle
person does the amendment you know going
in and eliminating that language you
know that says hey this is but not
limited to is that adequate to address
those concerns or do we need to inm
study that so I guess I'm just throwing
that question out there to those folks
who had those concerns to maybe give
some feedback to to let me know where
they're at at this point Thank you Mr
chair representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you representative
Weber for bringing this amendment I
think that you've clarified quite a few
things but I think I have even more
questions now I don't know what the
outpatient services set by the American
Society of addiction medicine are I
don't know what that includes and I
don't know what that's going to um
impact I I think that this is a highly
complex
issue and it's one where when it was
brought forth it seems like um it seems
like some of the issues that this was
designed to solve were actually
happening in residential facilities
where they should already be licensed so
I think that that while it would be
great to be able to do something right
now this amendment helps but I really
think that um we need to truly take a
look at this and truly work on this as
an interim study so that we can figure
out what the right approach is because
you're right fly by night uh recovery
clinics are not the right way to go
about it but how do we know that this
process is going to fix it and when you
look at the entire context of it too
with the rul making process this is
going to take time in order to figure
out how to get it done and how to do it
correctly and because of that time frame
because of that need because we're
trying to figure out all these balances
I I don't want to rush into something
that's not going to be the right
solution and then we're trying to figure
it out and then we need to come in and
change it next year as opposed to us
spending the time to to meet with those
who are addressed and impacted talk and
see if AA would fall underneath this see
if other peer recovery would fall
underneath it and just ensure that we're
not making things worse in the process
of trying to make things better uh
because quite frankly you know some of
those big headline Grabbers should have
been covered and we're not doing
anything to make sure that
um there's there's a lot of different
things we could look to I mean when you
look at sexual assault a provider has
certain restrictions and things that
could be done from an adult to an adult
are not acceptable if there's a provider
if somebody is not free to go in a
prison or another situation anybody who
has that control and power cannot have a
sexual relationship with somebody
because of that imbalance of power we
have nothing like that for sober homes
or people who run them so and this is a
significant issue actually in recovery I
know people who have relapsed because um
whether it was somebody who was in the
program and providing oversight or even
just another person in recovery you know
once you become a linked pair it's hard
enough for one person to get out of
addiction then having a pair um becomes
more challenging when you have a new
partner your whole whole identity as a
couple is recovery and then one one
person hits a stumble it can pull the
other one back in quite tightly
obviously we can't deal with the peer
issues um but the fact that we have
nothing to address address that
imbalance of Power with people who were
in recovery systems that's a significant
issue and one of the things that this
bill um seems to have addressed so I I I
think that this will make us feel good
but I'm not sure that it's actually
going to solve anything since the
problems happen at already licensed um
facilities other discussiones
representative
Shapiro um this certainly doesn't
um answer all those questions but in
regard to an independent practitioner
it's if you look at the amendment line
10 it's it explicitly says that
independent
providers um are exempt from this
certification so it would not the
language says that it would not include
um a a sole proprietorship Private
Practice type situation um
and I mean I
guess I guess definitions can always be
stretched and but it certainly seems
clear enough to me that that there are
very specific things that are included
in this amendment and they do not
include AA or anything that um sounds
like um that kind of um volunteer
self-help kind of um group
um so anyway I just wanted to respond to
the thing about private practitioners
they are explicitly excluded from this
representative
Kofa uh thank you Mr chairman so I I
think in the the the hearing and in this
discussion I've heard statements that we
all agree there's a problem
um I I respectfully do not agree that
there is a demonstrated problem
um I find it very interesting that in
the
hearing one of the cases that was cited
multiple times as a
justification uh for why we need
this pertained to licensed healthc care
facilities something that occurred in
licensed Health Care Facilities um I do
remain concerned about what happens with
um some of these you know faith-based
programs
AA things like that I I think my my big
concern about this is that it is
creating broad sweeping regulatory power
um
where I don't think that we have
substantiated a need for it if we were
to go interum study with this bill I
think that that would provide an
opportunity to uh to to look at it in
more detail to understand if there's a
need but you know the response that I I
kept hearing was well that's exactly why
we need regulation is because we don't
have visibility okay well there's
there's you either have visibility and
there's a problem or you don't have
visibility and you need visibility
um I think that we would be well served
by um speaking to a broader spectrum of
constituents and not just the uh three
or four people who who showed up at the
hearing to speak in support of the bill
representative
Weber I was just going to say that in
light of the confusion that people had
originally which I will be the first to
concede that this does not completely
resolve uh um I wonder if rather than
arguing back and forth over this it
would be helpful if we were to take a
straw poll on how many people were
interested in an interim study because
if that's the sense of the committee I
don't want to take up the committee's
time um trying to explain something that
came to me from people I trust but which
I have an imperfect understanding of
um so I just offer that as a possible
way forward uh thank you that's
something we may ask when the chair gets
back from his phone call I did look up
Outpatient Treatment with the American
Society of um addiction medicine so um
the level one treatment I'm going to
read the description and then let's fig
then um see if people want to see what
that fits into it's services that assist
an individual or group of individuals to
achieve treatment objectives through the
exploration of substance use disorders
their
ramifications including an examination
of attitudes and feelings and
consideration of alternative Solutions
and decision-making with regard to
Alcohol and Other Drug related Pro
problems um so this was this is me just
working on the fly to understand this to
me I've never been to AA but I have read
the book um and to me it seems similar
to that um I don't know if there's I'm
not asking anybody to say that they have
the experience but I it's it seems a
little close to me representative Nagel
this is my my concern and this goes back
to that whole harm reduction thing you
know we we relied on um you know as for
you know our our definitions but we
looked at what they said and we wrote
them down very specifically rather than
making a reference to it and I don't
personally think you should have to go
to some other source to figure out what
you're talking about I think if you're
going to say that you need to say what
it is you're saying that's my opinion
thank you uh representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also want to
thank representative Weber for um
working on the
amendment what again I'm may even trying
to get too far into the weeds here but
on line four the amendment it talks
about a certification process not a
certification so what I'm trying to
wrestle with in that are we talking
about how they become certified or what
the requirements are for them to become
certified so what I'm trying to
understand is that I go back to
mentioned before is that it's the
individuals in a program that causes the
abuse not the program itself nor the
facility so I want to be sure that
somehow in the certification process
whatever we're talking about the
program how it's going to be developed
and what the requirements are within
that program because I really concern
myself with professionals and I'll go
back and say something quickly on the
issue of regulatory um
overload there's many times in which 95
% of people want to do the right thing
and 5% of the people who don't and the
95% of people who are doing the right
thing Are burdened by the regulatory
environment because they're going to do
it anyways the 5% who don't want to deal
with the regulatory issues probably
going to ignore the regulations anyways
so I want to be careful that we don't
somehow take the ones that are doing the
best to be doing the right thing that we
don't create more burden on them to try
to protect the people from the 5% so
that's what I'm trying to get to repres
Senor Weber so this bill was presented
to us as a way to allow the department
to start writing the rules that would
answer the questions about what the
process was and things like background
checks and other things that have been
suggested ought to be in
there uh that said I do concur with the
idea that it's always better to have the
actual standards in rather than a
reference to something else Mr chairman
when you were out of the room I said
that I asked
that it
seems like it might
be helpful given the questions that
everybody has and what I'm hearing from
members of the committee who've spoken
if we took a straw pole on interm study
rather than proceeding
immediately to try and parse this out uh
because that might make things clearer
and then again it might not uh that was
my offer of a suggestion that might help
um if it
doesn't or if people don't want to do
that I'm more than happy to proceed as
as we've gone on I think it's a good
suggestion any objections to a straw
poll
on on interim
study how is that usually done by show
of hands or yeah yeah okay all those who
would be favorable to interim study as
else all those
opposed okay apparently most F most of
the committee favors interim study um I
would be willing to withdraw my motion
if the seconder who I've now forgotten
who it was is that represent can is also
willing to okay and thank you for you
know your efforts in bringing this
forward and Mr Barry thank you for your
efforts
also um we we knew it was a complex
issue from last week's hearing and uh we
knew it was going to be a heavy lift to
try to get it through since such a
compressed time frame and you know at
least an effort was made I'm sorry it
didn't well we don't know what's going
to happen but it looks like it's going
to be interim study so anyway do I have
a motion for interim study at this point
representative
mlan uh yes Mr J I'd make a motion for
interim study on S
sp495 okay
um oh representative McKay seconds okay
thank
you okay motion is interim study on S
sp495 FN uh is there any discussion on
the motion representative P off I just
uh want to State and double on what
representative
said that um uh why I agree with intent
of solving problem I don't agree with uh
presumptions in the bill that more
regulation will solve the
problem thank you any other yes
representative Weber I just wanted to
say thank you very much for allowing me
to present the amendment because
absolutely I'm glad to have it
considered well absolutely and you know
again as I as I said earlier I want all
all departments to feel that we we try
to consider all aspects of every bill
McKay I was going to say Thank you Mr
Speaker don't say that I don't want to
be speaker I don't think you want that
um I wanted to thank representative
Weber for what she did uh this is a very
valuable uh part that we can use in
interim study uh I wore myself out the
other day
uh uh unusual for me this type of
subject is extremely important to me and
I think to everybody else it's a very
complex uh subject and I think interim
study opens it up for us uh to get at
the the complexity of the subject I've I
don't know how many years I've been here
but it's all been for mental health
issues and uh we've got massive
information in the department including
the 10year plans that go back years and
years uh so that I think
the department was
concerned with where we were at this
point with this legislation I think
they're reassured that if we go to
interim study we're going to come up
with
legislation that deals with a very
important part of our uh
population that is often
misunderstood and I go back to the point
where New Hampshire hospital was a
terrible place I've never criticized
them because they did the best they
could until thorine came
along the there is much more that we can
do now based on what we know and it's
that that I would like to see that the
state takes responsibility for and
that's my purpose for supporting interim
study to to use the information we
already have and to strengthen what is
now a very good program thank you Mr
Speaker Mr chairman thank
you all right any other discussion on
the motion of interim study
representative mlan yeah I just want to
say I
mean man Manchester is Ground Zero when
it comes to you know uh issues with with
substance abuse and talking to the
people on the ground there this is a
real issue um and and so I do appreciate
representative who you bringing forth
the amendment because it certainly
clarified and distilled a lot of stuff
in my mind but I I do want to make sure
that we get it right and I do think that
this is such an important issue that if
we do bring it to interim study we are
going to get lots of input from lots of
different stakeholders and I think it's
going to be very valuable and um that's
all I have to
say any other
discussion seeing none I'll ask color
call the all a motion is interim study
on Senate Bill 495 FN representative Lon
yes representative ner yes clerk votes
yes representative kofel yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
POF yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative nut
upam representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representative TZ
yes and repres McDonald yes 19 to1
passes is there objection to consent no
thank
you okay uh next up is Senate Bill 496
FN representative Bill King did you have
a motion yes
um I'd like to make a I'd like to move
to um itl in expedient to legislate
okay uh motion's been made in expedient
to legislators there a second
representative representative
kofalt
um repres okay sorry sorry I'll second
it okay we get SEC two seconds um
representative Bill King do you want to
speak to your
motion yes I I want to start by saying
that um I am a believer
in climate change in environmental
impacts that are Happ happening from the
climate change so um my my objection to
this bill has nothing to do with that um
I will also note that uh climate change
has been happening ever since Noah's
flood but uh it has definitely increased
in recent years um uh the objection I
have to this bill is that um I think
that it's going to overtax uh DHHS
they're already involved in a lot lot of
different uh things within the state and
um uh and actually somebody who came to
speak for the bill actually convinced me
not to vote for the bill and it was uh
somebody who had a not for-profit and is
doing a very very good job coming up
with Solutions and so my my I think my a
lot of times we agree on the premise of
a bill and we've heard a lot of that
this morning already and yet we don't
agree on the solution so I think the
solution is to actually have not for
profits look at this rather than having
state and government look into um trying
to come up with a solution for us and
that's why I would like to iil this
bill he other discussion representative
um Merchant then representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair also I concur with
what representative uh Bill King said I
looked at the bill there's no funding
mechanism in this bill and given the
fact that the Department of Health Human
Services being on the oversight
committee it does a gallant effort to
accomplish what we ask it to accomplish
to ask them to do more things with no
funds it's almost like an unfunded
mandate to the department I think it's
unfair to the department I think at this
point in time I do believe in the bill I
just oppose it because there's no
funding mechanism for the Department to
have the resources to accomplish exactly
what we're asking it to accomplish I
know it says they can have grants and so
forth out there um Department could do
that on its own without legislative
Authority um I just for those reasons I
don't want to support the bill I'll
support the the motion to
itl other discussion representative
Shapiro yes I'm going to vote against
itl um well at the same time I
understand some of the reasoning um that
itl is being considered first I think um
seems accurate to me that um the
Department of Health and Human Services
could already do this without
legislation in fact I think we heard
testimony that they are doing this in in
many respects they talked about
tickborne illnesses and keeping data on
certain um Health outcomes that might be
related to climate I just for myself
personally I just feel like we are the
are the health and human services
committee um and we should send a strong
message that we think that climate
should be taken into consideration in
terms of the future health of our state
and
unfortunately um unlike representative
King there are a lot of people who
absolutely do not believe this is an
issue so I think as the subject matter
committee um this is an opportunity for
at least me to to to take a stand and
send a message that this is important
and should be looked at um as much as
possible uh representative Weber then
representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman I I share
an awful lot of what was said by the two
previous speakers um here's the way I
come out on it as I read this bill it
doesn't have a lot of
substance um it and and it certainly
doesn't have any funding it does have um
a direction to look for Grants and it is
a position that did exist at one
point um I am going to vote against the
itl because I want to affirm the policy
in here but it's a close call for me um
and
um I I I wish there was more substance
here I would be fighting a lot harder if
there was more substance rather than
less but I think it's a measure that
doesn't hurt and therefore I'm going to
vote against the itl because um I am for
supporting the underlying policy
representative cofal thank you Mr
chairman so I I I guess there were a
couple of examples that were brought up
when we asked sort of what would this
position do what would it focus on and
the three that I recall um related to uh
warning people or informing people uh
regarding tickborne ill illnesses uh the
second one had to do with uh wildfires
in Canada and the the smoke that was uh
was drifting down into New England and
the third had to do with educating
people about heat related injuries like
heat stroke um I don't understand why we
need a separate position to do any of
those things I don't understand why any
of those things would be outside of the
purview of the Department currently um
it seems to me that by um authorizing
this position or you know even with or
without funding we are we are
essentially creating a a a hole that the
next legislature is going to need to
fill um with with funding um so I think
the the for me the the debate is not um
how any of us necessarily feels about CL
CL change per se the debate is um is is
this is this necessary is it effective
um does it does it really do anything
and as far as I can tell um there's
nothing that this bill would enable that
is not
already possible as an activity per se
not I'm not speaking of to to a position
but um there's nothing there's nothing
that this bill says we should do that we
department the discussion
representa uh thank you Mr chair uh I
don't uh agree on premises of this bill
and specifically on future actions and
legislations that uh this uh uh
legislation would enable uh because uh
those policies can and will backfire
um for example we have problems with
sticks but uh if green policies allow
more forest and high deer population
High de population brings more tis uh we
do have a risk in New Hampshire from
future hurricanes but if we allow more
trees that will uh eventually fall on
houses uh it will backfire uh if we put
our Emergency Services on electrical
vehicles
uh and states around us uh threaten our
uh energy Supply by enabling green
energy policies we will end up with
emergency vehicles not able to serve us
so I'm afraid about uh consequences of
such
legislation okay any other
discussion representative Lon uh thank
you Mr chairman um my questions arise on
on um the fact that this can be done
through the Department of Health and
Human Services and then how much
validity this would give to a National
Climate emergency that may be declared
by the White House and whether or not
the commissioner needs to take actions
for that National Climate emergency
under the more broad-reaching authority
of the commissioner of the Department of
Health and Human Services relative to
other Commissioners and other other
people in the executive branch other
than the governor um we we have to look
at whether we're trying to to look at
first and second order causes or third
and fourth order causes we have our
issues with tickborne diseases and
regardless about what causation we have
we know that Lyme disease is an issue we
know that some of these other that may
make my life miserable if I become
allergic to meat end up moving here into
New Hampshire um I think that trying to
get into those second third fourth order
causes just really dilutes the effort
because we task the Department of Health
and Human Services with doing so many
different things this is something where
we have experts all over that are
collecting data we have guidelines that
are coming from other areas the idea of
trying to collect and analyze data we
have um on another bill um collecting
and analyzing data relative to um
cannabis legalization that one's costing
$200,000 a year because we have some of
the collection costs and then we have a
salary cost that's over
$100,000 if we're not going to fund this
then we get into other challenges and
the more unfunded positions we have the
more challenges we run into because we
ask the department to do something and
then we don't give them the resources um
I know that I personally apologized
after working to pass a bill last term
that we should have funded um and we had
to come back through this entire process
with 1669 to make sure that we had the
funds necessary for the Department to do
their job so the idea of doing this and
moving forward on this I I I just don't
think is a good use of State resources
when we have so many other areas that
are more pressing need that are more
directly related to the efforts here in
the state you know everything else we're
doing to address Health will'll already
address these areas which are trending
and becoming more prevalent and um I
just want to keep us Mission focused on
health and you know perhaps let
environment and a or resources whoever
deals with more of the climate change
issues worry about that because
regardless of of what's changing the
prevalence of different diseases we
focus on the health um we have other
other other committees that deal with
more of the climate change
issues other
discussion I'm seeing none before I put
the question to the committee uh I don't
know exactly where this is going to end
up um but three of us excuse me four of
us are do an Edna on another bill in 15
minutes and in the event that we go to a
second vote on this it's going to be
calling it a little tight so before I
put the question I'm thinking that
perhaps representative Murphy you and I
and representative TZ and representative
Nagel should go on to Edna uh on another
bill it's a it's it's Senate Bill 440 we
at one point we thought it might come to
this committee it's only going to them
but um I I don't want to be late for
that so um I'm just thinking in the
event this goes to a second vote uh and
it get be a split vote might be safer to
as representative Maguire I he runs a
pretty tight ship Miss representative of
can we do a straw poll um sure couldn't
we just take the first vote and then
we'll know where we are it will take us
three minutes oh okay and then and then
we don't have to the people for the
first vote wouldn't have to S around for
the stick around for the second vote
you're saying everybody can go on mass
if they need to yeah okay all right all
right in that case um representative
Bill King has made a motion of
itl uh on Senate Bill 496 FN and I'll
ask him to call a all representative Lon
yes representative ner yes clerk votes
yes repres representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelosof yes representative Weber
no representative M no
Representative fedus
no representative
Canon
upam representative Shapiro
no represent a
merchant no yes sorry yes sorry I
ideal double negatives representative
Murphy no no
no representative Palmer no represent
TZ
No and representative McDonald
yes 12 to8 representative Weber you were
right as you often
are
okay I assume they'll be a Minority
Report uh we'll we'll discuss among
ourselves but we understand you need did
this afternoon okay great thank you very
much um and I would just with the last
one I abjure my colleagues that when you
have the votes stop talking and
representative Le on when I said that
the first time said and when you don't
have the votes stop talking so um I
should have probably said that
okay so I'll just make a note there will
um thank you okay and with that uh the
next bill could go on a bit I know
that's a a little bit of a contentious
issue on um those those pills those
contraception pills so I think it would
be a good time uh for the four of us to
go on to Edna again it's two Republicans
and two Democrats
so um you folks want to join me uh and
I'll leave the gabble with the vice
chairman thank you madam Vice
chairman thank you um and with that I
will open the executive session on
Senate Bill
567 and uh representative mizor do you
have a
motion yes thank you madam chair I'd
like to motion to itl and I'll second
that sorry sorry on SB 567
okay and I'll second that would you like
to speak to your motion yes um it's
just confusing and honestly concerning
why we're singling out just these two
drugs for a report why not compile a
report on the availabil availability of
other drugs and um we have no real data
to show that this is an actual problem
so that's why I I don't see the need for
this
Bill thank you uh representative Weber
thank you madam chair uh I see a need
for the study because of the increased
attacks on the availability of various
sorts of reproductive health care and we
know that in this state we have places
where there is less Health Care rather
than more and so I would very much like
to see this report done thank you thank
you thank you representative Merchant
thank you madam chair
um I think it's important that we
collect sort of
a landscape of what's happening in the
state in regards to the availability of
these medications I would also say that
this could be done without going through
uh a legislative process if the
department wanted to do this they could
do it today work with a Board of Nursing
Board of Pharmacy um Board of Medicine
places in which the data could be
collected today with going through a
legislative process so I don't say
support the bill because I think is are
the Avenues to gain the data without
having to go through a legislative
process thank you representative Weber
and then representative Seth
King and I would just say that it is our
purview as a legislator as a legislature
and as individual legislators to direct
the department as to what information we
would like to have gathered uh because
while they have the ability to do so
they also have as we've said a number of
times before many other things that they
are also doing so I think this is a
matter of policy for the legislature and
I think that um I will be voting in
favor of the underlying
chair is it Madam chair my
apologies okay thank you madam chair and
thank you for the correction um
this build um I just think it sets a bad
precedent um I mean how how would we
feel if all of a sudden the gun rights
people decided to say we need to have a
bill we need to have a report on the
availability of guns in North Country
because there's an attack on gun rights
all across the United States and there
just might not be enough people to you
know I mean we could play this game for
so many different
ideas and this isn't achieve anything if
if these people if people want these
drugs they can get them and this is this
is more like a a statement than anything
real and I just I don't want to see us
go down that path so I'll be voting itl
thank
you um thank you and I'll speak briefly
to this um I I think that conflating
what's happening in New Hampshire with
what's happening in the rest of the
country is a dangerous idea here in New
Hampshire I think that the six week that
we have is one that many people can
agree upon um I know that when I'm
speaking when people come to me and say
I'm pro-choice where are you um the six
month is something that's rational to
them the state of New Hampshire even
though there are a few legislators who
are putting in very early bills those
are soundly defeated New Hampshire is a
very different state than some of the
other states within this Union um and
quite frankly it appears that the prime
sponsor of this bill may have an ability
to look at this at the federal level if
uh she's successful but I don't think
that this is really necessary to the
state of New Hampshire so that's why I
seconded it so S I don't know if there's
any other discussion or if we want to I
guess we want to make sure that
everybody who should be in here is
actually here if we do call a vote so
check3 14 that's 16 16 minus 4 means
we're only missing the people that we
were counting on not being here perfect
thank
you okay and with that um I will ask the
clerk to call the
role represent sorry and the motion is
in expedient is uh in expedient to
legislate representative Lan um um oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry wait just a
second representative
cofal
yes representative ner yes
clerk votes
yes representative McAn
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel I'm sorry uh he's not here uh
representative pelosof yes
representative Weber
no representative McKay
no representative fedus
representative Canon no representative
Nutter
upam representative
no G Merchant no vote oh no he's here
he's here it's all
morning representative Merchant can I
representative Murphy I'll wait for you
not to the comment and then I'll okay
representative Palmer
no representative
TZ is not here and representative
McDonald representative Lon
yes 10 to six motion
passes and I'll write a Minority Report
on pass okay
thank you all for your time and being
here today and thank you for the
flexibility as we were moving between
here and the Senate uh representative
kofalt um did we finish up with
355 or do we need to return to
355 I I think we finished 3 no
recommendation on 350 oh we okay I was
yes thank you sorry about that Madam
chair representative South K yeah I'd
like to say a quick quick apology
I'd like to say a quick apology for
earlier when I called the vaccine stupid
that came off as unnecessarily harsh
that was not my intention so sorry thank
you for that thank
you um and we will see everybody bright
and early tomorrow I'm not sure we'll
see which time we're noticed for um as
9:30 um the because it's that we're
hearing the bill the same day so um we
do not need to notice as long as there's
agreement between the chair and the
ranking member there's already agreement
between the chair and the ranking member
um the the biggest question though is I
know that some people will be getting up
to testify in other bills um we'll just
need to figure out how we accommodate
that in order to accommodate our subs um
and representative Weber and I would
remind people that the sponsors don't
actually have to be there if you have
somebody
else have them bring your remarks and
your sentiments
um but be here for the vote if you
possibly can uh but but that having been
said you know I think it's an important
bill there was an inadvertent error and
I think it behoves all of us to
cooperate in in coming to a resolution
and it's also a second committee bill so
yes and thank you for that and also um
this morning those bills had very slim
representation in that and we wanted to
make sure our hard work didn't go um
wasn't wasn't Left Behind as we moved to
the other body um the ones tomorrow
morning morning that people may be
moving to we going to be longer so
they'll be able to shuffle us around so
um my hope would be that we can do this
um we can hopefully exective soon after
um as opposed to waiting L later in the
day since they are holding the calendar
for us so with that I will close our
executive session today thank you all